♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" FOR THE
PRESIDENT HOLDING A RALLY IN
PANAMA CITY, FLORIDA.
WE'LL GO TO IT LIVE WHEN HE
BEGINS SPEAKING.
ONE THING WE ARE GOING TO BE
WATCHING FOR IS WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT RESPONDS TO THE
SEISMIC STORY THAT BROKE LAST
NIGHT ON CABLE NEWS.
HERE'S HOW THEY SUMMARIZED IT.
>> WITH C AND THEN TONIGHT, I'M
DON LEMON.
ARE YOU LISTENING?
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS A FRAUD AND A
CON MAN.
>> Tucker: HOLY SMOKE SIX MAKE
THIS SOUND LIKE A BIG
DEVELOPMENT.
WHAT HAPPENED?
DID THE PRESIDENT GET CAUGHT
RUNNING A NIGERIAN PHONE SCAM?
DID HE SELL BED CALLING?
DID HE SPEND TWO FULL YEARS OF
THE RUSSIAN INCLUSION HOAX WAS
REAL?
NO, NOTHING THAT SLEAZY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REVEALED
THAT SOME OF TRUMP'S BUSINESS IS
LOST QUITE A BILL OF MONEY.
BECAUSE OF THAT, HE PAID NO
FEDERAL INCOME TAXES FOR EIGHT
OF THE TEN YEARS FROM WHERE THEY
HAD DATED.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS A COMMON
WAY TO ACCOUNT.
SOME OF THE BIGGEST COMPANIES IN
THE WORLD PAID NO FEDERAL INCOME
TAXES WERE EXACTLY THE SAME
REASON.
THAT LIST WOULD INCLUDE AMAZON,
DELTA AIRLINES, CHEVRON,
GENERAL MOTORS.
CNN HASN'T SET A LOT OF THAT.
THEY WERE TOO BUSY GLOATING OVER
TRUMP'S TAXES FROM THE REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
INTRODUCING MR. DON LEMON.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT
CASINO GAMBLING.
THE HOUSE ALWAYS WINS?
[LAUGHS]
NOT ALWAYS.
NOT IF IT'S A TRUMP CASINO.
WHO LOSES THEIR MONEY AT A
IN A CASINO?
"I'M GOOD ENOUGH, SMART ENOUGH,
AND GOD GONE
DAG GUN, PEOPLE LOVE ME."
>> Tucker: DON LEMON IS EASILY
AMUSED.
WHEN THE WHOLE POINT OF YOUR
NETWORK IS TO ATTACK A SINGLE
PERSON?
THIS IS A MAJOR STORY.
FROM HIS SHADOW WE LAY HER HEAD
AND HIGH ABOVE THE NEWSROOM,
CNN'S SECRETIVE WHARF
KING SLITHERED TO THE
FROM ACROSS THE CABLE EMPIRE,
>> LOST MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
NEXT BIGGEST LOSER IN THIS
COUNTRY.
SO HE'S LITERALLY THE BIGGEST
LOSER.
HIS LOSSES WERE MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE NEXT BIGGEST LOSER IN THE
COUNTRY.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY THIS IS WHY
HE DOESN'T WANT ANYONE TO HAVE
THIS INFORMATION?
THAT HE'S SUCH A LOSER, HE CALLS
PEOPLE LOSERS, HAS SUCH DISDAIN.
HE WAS LITERALLY THE BIGGEST
LOSER IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: TRUMP LOST MONEY!
IT'S A GOOD THING CNN IS ON THAT
STORY, OTHERWISE NO ONE WOULD
HAVE GUESSED THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAD FINANCIAL PROBLEMS IN THE
EARLY 1990s.
EXCEPT PEOPLE WHO WERE ALIVE
THEN.
OR PEOPLE WHO HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS NOW.
30 YEARS AGO, TRUMP'S PERSONAL
DEBT CRISIS WAS NATIONAL NEWS.
INSIDE HIS WALLET, TRUMP PAPERS
REVEALED HUGE DEPTH, READ THE
TABLOIDS.
TRUMP IN A SLUMP.
EVEN DAVID LETTERMAN MOCKED A
TRUMP WITH A TOP TEN LIST, TOP
TEN SIGNS THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
IN TROUBLE.
IN THE END, DONALD TRUMP
RECOVERED BE HE MADE THE
DISASTER PART OF HIS BRAND, HE
MADE A BOOK ABOUT IT CALLED "ART
OF THE COMEBACK."
WHEN HE LOST HIS REALITY SHOW
"THE APPRENTICE," HE BRAGGED
ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
>> 16 YEARS AGO, I WAS BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN DEBT.
BUT I FOUGHT BACK AND I WON.
BIGLY.
>> Tucker: WHAT WE LEARNED
LAST NIGHT WASN'T REALLY NEWS
BUT WHAT'S NEWS IS YOU CAN STEAL
SOME OF THE PRIVATE TAX
INFORMATION, PUT IT ON
TELEVISION, AND THE BODY EVEN
PAUSES OR ASKS WHETHER THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA, MUCH LESS A INVASION
OF PRIVACY.
ARE THOSE THE RULES NOW?
ACCORDING TO RULES, THOSE ARE
THE RULES NOW.
DEMOCRATS
LAWMAKERS ARE FORCING THE
RELEASE OF TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS.
HOW ABOUT HIS MEDICAL RECORDS?
HOW ABOUT HIS INTERNET SEARCH
HISTORY?
HOW ABOUT HIS TRANSCRIPTS OF HIS
PHONE CALLS?
WHY NOT?
AND IF PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIKE
DONALD TRUMP CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT HIM, WHAT
ABOUT THOSE OF US WHO DO NOT
LIKE C AND THEN
CAN WE GET DON LEMON'S TAX
RETURNS?